[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're going to be talking
about our big 2020 initiative let's make
it sound as corporate as possible the
big 2020 initiative from rhett and Link
is vlogging on the long term fallow
rhett and Link channel you know what
fallow I thought you were gonna say
something else when you started saying
fat long long term fellow I don't know
what I was gonna say long fallow lie is
even worse yeah we're gonna hollow is if
is when you leave you don't plan
anything in a field right there's been
nothing planted on the not barren but
fallow because baring would
intentionally never produced anything
but it produced a lot of things yeah and
so you leave it fellow
it's called crop rotation yeah well no
crop rotation is when you plant
something different well and then it
like stores nutrients isn't nothing
something weeds like weeds grow up in a
field for those of you who are confused
we're talking about the fact that we are
launching very soon
vlogs on the rhettandlink channel the
what we called the main channel forever
every Saturday we're gonna be doing that
we're gonna be talking about what went
into that decision what you can expect
you know it's it's it is a little bit
odd to start the year talking about you
know why we're making a particular
decision but it's such a but you know
what that's what 2020 is about it's
about making decisions I think one we're
very excited about but two it it I think
it was a big decision so it's in and
nothing's out yet so it's it still seems
like well what's good what's gonna be
over there why are you doing this it's
kind of our only resolution I don't have
any other resolutions besides that so
we're just going to talk about our
intention to have it's a I think it's a
big deal not not just have them it's not
just doing something on that channel but
deciding to do vlogs deciding to shoot
it in
we're gonna shoot it shoot it it they
were gonna shoot it it I don't know
everything that will end up talking well
but I didn't do it because there's
there's so much involved that went into
the decision and there's some there's so
much excitement from us and hopefully
from a lot of mythical beasts that is
worth talking about I will say next week
we'll be talking about our holidays are
separate but equal oh I don't know if
there he calls me for yourself are
different but definitely need to update
each other on what happened of our
holiday so that so that'll be next week
but this week it's more dislike creat
the creative juices are there they're
electrified it's like we're on the
precipice of a new thing ma are just
flowing I'm not I'm not bad I'm not my
juices are flowing but I don't I'm not
adding electrical charge to them because
I guess dangerous at that point when you
start putting electricity into water
mm-hmm
which is a good way to make it boil I
actually I tuned out for one second I
have no clue what you're talking doesn't
matter you know what before we get into
the whys and the how's and the what's of
you're not about to do an ad I'm not I'm
gonna do it I feel like people already
trying to like hit the skip button when
you say but before we don't know that's
the moment people are like hitting that
15 second forward nobody does that for
us nobody because they know and if you
did you feel stupid now because now you
just realize this is not an ad and I'm
telling you a story but you actually do
want to hear
I like our ads I'd like to listen I have
a audible I've had an interaction with
my with my neighbor that I thought okay
this is the thing that we do now we
update each other with our interactions
with our neighbors I thought I would do
that so it's a tree name no different
different this is a neighbor I didn't
know I had let me explain
I haven't thought about how I'm gonna
tell the story but I realized about it
now this is a better just take it just
take a beat I got it I didn't think
about how it was
once they stare at change my figure well
I'm not figuring out I'm just gonna
continue telling the story okay
so you know how I'm gonna make my like
pool slash backyard area better than
yours that's what I'm doing 2020 yeah
cuz it hasn't been for right yeah a
number of years so I'm in the process of
doing that before I make it better than
links what I have to do is I have to
make it worse than it is because I have
to demolish it right unenjoyable totally
unlivable currently it isn't a
completely deconstructed State there's
everything they just tore everything
down and basically piled it in a corner
the guys have gone into the pool and
like jack-hammered off the surface so it
just kind of looks like a
post-apocalyptic scene but you like that
in my like yard area and of course I'm
still making decisions about some of the
final like design points and where
things are gonna go and so I just went
out there yesterday
mm-hmm and I'm just like I mean I was
probably just out there just standing in
spiked kind of just looking it's
standing in one place and looking at
different things and just thinking
visualize five to seven minutes and all
of a sudden I hear you got a mess down
there and that was like god is that you
you're right wasn't that echoing boo me
it came from on high okay it came from
above me which freaked me out a lot
because I've lived in this house for
four years and this has never happened
yeah so I look to the skies you looked
up and I didn't see the clouds part what
I saw is a man standing now this is what
I was about to say but now I was able to
tell the story in a funny way now I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna orient you in a
way that well you'll understand what
this voice was coming from so as is
typical when you kind of live on a hill
sometimes like so I live this spot on
the hill and then like my backyard is
basically almost a vertical wall of
Earth that goes up and then other
people's yards start their backyards all
looking the same way and terraced above
you yeah and so there are people who
live up there and I'd like driven on the
road that runs parallel to my road and I
can like oh yeah I don't know these
people we've never had any interactions
yeah except for one older couple on the
other side what light right when we
moved in they were up there kind of
looking off into the distance and we
talked to them but this guy's like did
they think you were Satan when you
looked up at him and said got a mess up
there
they look down thinking you were no I
just said I just said oh hey cuz
basically if at the top of the wall of
dirt or planted of sorts there's like
people's fences right yeah and so right
in the middle of my lot
there is two people's houses like their
Lots kind of come together so that their
Lots meet and split kind of where my lot
is so I can see two people's yards up
there so one of the yards this guy's
standing in the corner you got two gods
and he is I I got a mess that was like
oh hey he was like I'm kin I was like
I'm Rhett okay and so he said got a mess
down there you said oh okay
I was like no he said I was laying no I
was like yeah got a lot of work to do
down here just getting started whatever
you know just typical BS I would have
said get down here get to work and it
was a little unsettling because let me
tell you why this was unsettling okay
because I know I just was like talking
like this but then we proceeded to have
a conversation at this volume talking
this loud I wasn't yelling at him I was
on the other side of my like across the
pool from him and he's all the way up
there and we're just talking in this
volume right here what did that
immediately make me think that I
I have no clue you say not like you have
superhuman hearing and he can't hear you
and I don't know if this I don't know if
you've thought this but it made me think
that oh I know that he's heard every
conversation you've had in your backyard
yes yes and I have this sense of
absolute privacy in my backyard because
insane some private stuff huh well I've
been back there for some private stuff
well I'm just saying I mean conversation
it's it made me think that so so I got
some some neighbors kind of off all the
way that houses come together it's very
odd cuz we're all on this hill and so
you know and one side of my pool I've
got like that giant like IV wall that's
actually what I was looking at there's
this giant there's a fence and then like
an IV wall but we've taken down like the
the awning like the roof parts and now I
can kind of like see through parts of
the IV and I can see oh there's a house
right there and their backyard comes up
to right here and like they have like a
little area that they can sit and like
if they were sitting right there while I
was in my hot tub like having a
conversation with my friends about
whatever I could just sit out there and
listen I could just listen and fertilis
lee and eat them even more so but then
Kim he could just come to the corner I
would never see Ken of the corner or Kim
could put out like a recording device he
just have it all what if he has a
whisper mm sounds like you don't need
one but if he did he could pointed right
at me yeah do they still have whisper mm
I barely it looks like a megaphone you
aim at stuff so you can hear the
conversation I always wanted one it's
like a spy device my family and I used
to joke about your whisper mm so often
it's the kind of thing that my dad would
really latch on to yeah he was really
making jokes about like the whisper mm
because I had a name whisper mm hmm is
it still a thing whisper mm anything
anyway so so what you're talking to Ken
you're thinking this at a time or you
elected upon I know I was thinking at
the time I was like I'm not having to
raise my voice at all I mean no not only
that but like you know anything that
I've said even things I've said in my
house
like where the windows open you know
sometimes the windows are open which at
that point I'm basically even with him
in the second story in now I've gotten
all the times that we've gotten in
fights the times I've told my kids to
you know my kids rooms are on the back
and the times I've gotten frustrated
with them and told them that whatever
I've told them oh goodness
yeah but you just started thinking your
arms off well having said that window
but you just you start thinking to
yourself that there's an illusion
there's an illusion of privacy and I
mean if you like live in an apartment or
you live in a lot of people live in
homes that they're right next to their
neighbor in California there's many many
homes where your wall on the side of
your house is you know a matter of feet
from the wall of the next house and so
anything going out of your house you
know in terms of audio could go into
their house and vice versa but I because
my life you think those who freely seem
so private and and I I don't really seem
like he knew stuff about you he's
talking well I just started thinking
what if I said there you know when I'm
in the hot tub you're yours you're
delirious it's so loose everything I'm
saying it's just like that water does
heat you up and your guard gets down and
you got you know there's a makes you
stupid take I think I mean there's a lot
I've had lots of friends in that hot tub
we've had great late night discussions
and something about late at night you
don't need a whisper mm cuz just the
sound just travels and I'm like these
people you know again I couldn't think
of anything that I've said that I would
be like there's nothing I've said in my
hot tub or in my house that I would be
necessarily embarrassed or ashamed to
have the world know but but there is but
at the same time there are things that
there's things that you you it was stuff
between friends I think stuff in your
family I think you needed you need to
have a heart-to-heart with kin you know
be like hey man I know you know stuff
about me
but you could also say but I know stuff
about you you don't they don't want to
mess with me there I don't know anything
you'd be lying at that point I didn't
know he existed yeah yeah I think it
you'd be lying I think it has to do with
the fact that where he's at he got the
high ground man he's got the high ground
and so his voice just shoots over the
top she'll surrender shoots over the top
of my house I think you're gonna have to
build a roof over your yard with like
some sort of soundproofing so you can
continue to speak the way that you
always do in your hot tub I well you
talk like a cone of silence but the cone
of silence is it like a decorative roof
yeah it could be tint saved I wonder if
anybody manufactures a giant cone of
silence
house sighs cone of silence I mean it's
not like you're protecting that much
information you look you gotta tighten
up in the hot tub a little bit but
here's the thing here's the thing that
you for some reason hasn't read God is
always listening here's what you hasn't
registered with you your house is even
worse well I've got my backyard I'm
overlooking I'm like I'm like kin to my
neighbor but you the angle is different
like an easel and he's further down you
can be hear what they're saying down
there but no one above me can hear what
I'm saying because my backyard doesn't
back against your side neighbors my side
neighbor can yeah the neighbor in
question yeah Mike hang on there my
neighbor I've been looking out my window
and we sit there at your little table
and eat you know we've had many meals
out there yeah and that's I mean they
put a little they put a little sitting
table right there behind the bush
- yeah they got close to you they set up
a table they put a table close proximity
to your table so they could whisper mm
us over there yeah I'll put up a
connoisseur I have a pergola I can just
I add some soundproofing to it it was
just a lower violence maybe we should
speak pig latin you know this is the rib
this is the other started doing that and
I'm like you know what this is the
original purpose of pig latin is to
confuse the unschool but i think
everyone knows pig latin now it also
complicates deep conversations yeah I
don't know what I'm gonna do Ken
if you're listening you're always
listening but I think I'm gonna just
talk quieter you start confessing the
king I mean it is very appropriate that
we're talking about this neighbor
shenanigans stuff because it plays
directly into what we're what we're
going to put on the rent link channel we
can talk about that more but first an
actual add this is the part that they're
skipping is that what you're saying yeah
but I mean in the video version look
it's just me pointing to my chest and
saying hey you want to purchase this
this is a nice refined pinstriped
mythical shirt all types of mythical
stuff at mythical calm and while this
shirt does what they call the Moray
effect because the the camera mechanism
cannot reconcile the clotheslines that
doesn't happen with a human eye so while
link looks literally electrified right
now that won't happen in real life and
unless you unless you want it to let's
focus assist Oh and that'll still happen
though no I'm just talking about this
part mythical calm get your something so
sell something that will do something
for yourself
moire on video that's the selling point
okay
it's 2020 we made it through the ads
we're still doing ads in 2020 we're not
gonna apologize for it maybe doing more
it's like we got a we got to keep we
gotta keep pushing the products so that
we can pay the bills you know how this
works
why don't we and then you can listen to
this for free yeah yeah don't complain
about the edge you get it for free
they're not complaining
you are alright so good don't complain
about that you get it for free you get
to listen back to this podcast for
freely I know I do
let's talk about the process that that
got us to this point yeah and I feel
like there's a number of sort of
independent events that led to where
we're at right now yeah right I do think
it's worth addressing the fact that
one of the big sort of key factors here
was deciding to stop doing L tat let's
talk about that on Saturdays mm-hmm
which then created a void if of content
you know it's funny like we haven't put
stuff out on the weekends for like years
and years and years and then we started
doing it and in the moment were like and
we can talk about some of the whys that
we decided not to do elta anymore we
were immediately like well what are we
gonna put there as opposed to we could
have been nothing and we said and it can
be nothing but but the wheels started
turning we started thinking about a lot
of things that led to the decision we
made but well let's talk about where you
stopped doing L tat because yeah I don't
wanna spend a lot of time talking about
this and I'm and I'm not gonna talk
about it in a defensive way if anything
linked what you xx that seemed defense
2020 is the year of not being defensive
about decisions that we've made well no
but we have but we have a tendency to I
like apologize apologize for decisions
that we make because you people get
attached to something and people say oh
I was starting to like this more than
this and now you're taking it away yeah
I you know again I'm not gonna apologize
for it like I said we we have our
reasons for doing it
but I think the main reason you know
what I'll apologize for it I'm sorry the
main reason that is why there's two of
us we're doing the sorry that we're not
doing elta anymore the the biggest
reason for it is what we had realized is
that alta had become very much as sort
of behind the scenes show where we would
talk about like an extra round from a
game that we didn't include on the main
gmm episode for time or whatever reason
or something that happened at the office
or like oh well there's the it became
this more behind-the-scenes thing and at
the same time as LT I became more and
more about that something else was
happening on the mythical society and
that is we're starting to realize after
kind of experimenting with different
things that on the society especially
with like what we tried to do last this
past summer we're all of a sudden if you
were a mythical Saida member you may
have remember that all of a sudden there
was all these like lieu experimental
shows
yeah like what some of the quadrant what
we kind of found is that it seems like
that wasn't something that people were
interested in and that most people were
members of the society when it came to
when it came to content they want access
they want they want to you know it's
like which is that's not access access
to us access to the experience that's
behind the experience just be closer to
the action like same behind the scenes
is kind of like kind of cheapens I think
what what people want well but I think
the reason for them is that is a way to
say society is to create a place where
people can get as close to the action as
we are comfortable with you getting
without you being kin up in the yard
above me
meaning that constantly monitor if
judging writing down how he's going to
breathe darting his all of your Lachlan
channel out so but the idea of you know
if you want to know about something
that's happening at mythical why it's
happening the people who work here you
know things that were thinking and doing
etc we're just realizing that that's
really the purpose of the mythical
society it's it's a is people who want
more than what they can get from all the
three stuff that we that we put out on
the Internet and into the world and
that's what the mythical society is and
so it was like the content that we're
conceptualizing for el tap especially as
we think about the society for 2020 it's
like the best home for this stuff is the
society now that don't misunderstand
that that doesn't mean that Alta is
going to be a show on the society but it
means that some of the things that would
have been featured on Elle tat us
reacting to things etc rounds from games
that we took out for time that stuff is
gonna live on the society along with a
lot of other stuff we're going to
continually be rolling stuff out over
there so that was the decision with alt
at which left this vacuum on Saturday
and I will add that the original conceit
was like okay
just as the talking dead is to the
walking dead let's talk about that will
be to G mmm
yet we we got to a point where there
wasn't enough referential stuff we
started having to create things that
were just for like original things for
elta that were you know it required a
decent amount of investment of time and
talent and resources yet it was so
inward focused and self referential that
by design elta was something that was
supposed to be an experience for
existing fans but not to reach out but
then when you find yourself investing a
lot of resources in trying to make that
happen it's hard to justify that and but
when that's what's wanted on the society
it's much easier to justify or an
investment of resources and creativity
at a place where people are paying for
it and we want to give them value for it
and so that ecosystem works from a
business stand another way everything
that we put out for free on the internet
is more or less designed to be something
that a first-time viewer or listener
could step into and get it and
appreciate it and want to be a part of
what we're doing yeah but if you have
actually bought into it and you're like
no I am a mythical beast this is a part
of my life I'm going to support you guys
in what you're doing
well now we have an avenue for that and
it's really a well those people are
willing to pay for it and we have to
provide a service that's worthy of being
paid for you know so it's like it's a
totally different business model and so
yeah once you find that you're creating
something outside for everybody to come
and watch and it really makes sense to
be something that's really for a
committed fan well that stuff is moving
more and more to be a part of the
mythical society so that means I'm very
proud of what Alta was and I'm you know
it
we weren't critical of the product as
much as everything we've already said
it's kind of a different assessment it
was a it was a lot of work for Stevie I
was a lot of work for Stevie B's our job
daven did a great as busy as anybody
at mythical but it ended up being you
know as like she was producing it and
she was hosting it it ends up being a
lot of work yeah it was a lot so once we
started talking about making that move
like I said we didn't have to fill
Saturdays with anything but we started
to think but what if we did what would
that look like and I mean we went
through a number of things like the
start of ideas but I don't there was
never like another idea that we or two
more ideas that we were like really
deliberating between we really the
brainstorming process led to the point
of us of us vlogging and I think that
came from and then the second decision
which we talked about was like the fact
that we didn't even put it on the good
mythical morning Channel yeah about that
secondarily I think there's III think
there's a number of things that kind of
led at this point and for me I kind of
see three three things I see number one
the decision to do to go back to Buies
Creek and shoot those those three
special episodes for Glee Creek the for
the bleed Creek conversations - I
remember the third one I just forgot the
second one the decision to do that
second is kind of observing what's
happening on YouTube and seeing people
do a particular thing and kind of
thinking man we could do that that for
me that was a motivating factor like
seeing people really connecting with the
audience in a certain way and knowing
that we would be good at it just kind of
naturally makes me want to do it but
then I think the third point is in the
midst of trying to get a lot of you know
a lot of people are like what do you
guys do when you're not doing GMM and I
think many of you now kind of understand
well a lot and one of the things that
we're always trying to do is we're
trying to get these what you might call
traditional projects off the ground so
things that require a different model of
financing when you have to go pit
something you have to talk to people you
have to develop ideas with people things
move really really slowly in that
traditional world where you're used to
you know we're used to being on YouTube
and it worked really slowly and then
odds are it'll never happen right and no
one will ever see it yes so that's
that's part of it yeah and so that's
something we want to continue to do
because there are certain ideas and
certain things we aspire to that can
only be accomplished with that business
model some of the biggest and best ideas
we have can only be brought to fruition
using that traditional business you come
out of television series among me
whatever movie I mean so we're gonna
keep trying to make those things happen
and they will happen but because they
can be frustratingly slow and like link
said they can have small chances of
actually happening we kind of just get
creatively antsy yeah and I think that
this decision to do these vlogs is
really an answer to want to try
something new and invigorating
creatively something that we could be
excited about yeah so to kind of go back
through those I think for the first one
we we we replayed the experience in the
assessment of when we went back to Buies
Creek and shot that dock you follow
stuff like basically making our own
little mini documentary and deciding to
put it within good mythical morning and
it was it was such a fun experience to
be in that mode again where it was like
we're at we're out of the studio were
being ourselves we're we're excited
about something about doing something
and it's being documented and we just
had this faith that okay without trying
too hard to to make it into something
let's just honestly pursue this goal and
have this hope that that will just come
across in the Edit and the people will
enjoy it and you did and that really
happened it was really encouraging so
yeah I think it did spark that creative
itch to do that again and if you go look
at some of the comments in this isn't
this wasn't necessarily we were already
thinking this but if you look at some of
the comments on those videos you will
see people say things like I would love
to see you guys
do like a blog of your lives and so it's
just okay people are making the
connection that this feels like that
kind of content which has become a genre
in and of itself right I think the the
other point and again we talked about it
at the end of the year with our top tens
because I was talking about the birthday
your birthday day yeah yeah and there's
there's two aspects of that there's like
there's the are cultivating our
friendship and sharing that experience
which I think we should like to come
back to that but then just the other
aspect of we were just filming Instagram
stories and it was a lot of fun so like
I think as opposed to the Buies Creek
documentary when we were just filming
ourselves on our phones and it was like
nobody else is there it kind of made it
even more exciting because it was all on
us yeah and it was the most honest
version of ourselves when we were doing
everything just documenting what we were
doing so I think we very quickly got to
let's film ourselves yeah
let's film each other we I mean we were
tossing around an idea just we were
driving somewhere and we started talking
about what if we this is before we came
up with this idea we're talking about
doing like a little mini scripted thing
where we play characters who are filming
themselves in each other on their phones
but it's very character-based and like
it will be totally scripted we got
excited about that on that one drive
maybe we'll do that in the future maybe
that'd be something on Instagram I mean
I don't know we're not actively pursuing
that right now but whenever we're
driving somewhere which we rarely do but
if you got to drive across town we end
up talking about things like this where
we will hatch an idea and then we'll
just like put it on the shelf so I'm
maybe it'll come back down off the shelf
but I do think when we revisited the
brainstorming that led to this we were
kind of sideways accessing the feeling
of the excitement from that idea in
saying let's let's film ourselves let's
just keep it as small as possible I also
think that's a reaction to and again
it's not a negative reaction to the fact
that we have a we have a
big team that every you know specializes
in so many different things and does so
many things much better than we can and
works within a system that's been
created to produce a bunch of content to
get it all out there
it's exciting to just kind of just go
back to our roots so it's not saying
anything negative about the team all of
that all that's positive and the fact
that we can brainstorm these ideas where
we can go off and shoot something
ourselves it's kind of a it's it's to
their credit but it's exciting to do
some of them that was like polar
opposite from that well I think more
specifically it's more in line with the
spirit of the internet so you know so to
your second point yeah well and also
when you think about good mythical
morning you know years ago once we
started making GMM our assumption was as
soon as GMM started working what we
thought was going to happen is that all
these people were gonna just cut like
we're gonna start doing what we do which
is they were gonna make a sort of
produced Daily Show that kind of feels
like the Internet's answer to a
talk-show now yes some people tried it
and there are some iterations of it out
there but I think what most people
quickly realize is that man this is
really hard it's it's really really hard
to do and do it for a long period of
time and to do it well for a long period
of time and the only reason we can do it
is because of the team that we built
around us that now like you said makes
it where it's it's a possibility but one
of the things that comes along with
really efficient processes being in
place for creating things like good
mythical morning is that you know
they're going to end up having a little
bit more of a polished and refined
quality to them like GMM kind of feels
like like I said YouTube's answers to a
television show right and it is
what it is and it really works and it's
worked for a long time and it is really
it's you know it has large like the
heart of GMM is still very much just us
just being friends together and
interacting with something right but it
doesn't have this DIY feel to it
because we had to lose the DIY feel in
order to do anything else so and now it
has this like Oh a studio makes this
show this shows coming from a group of
people yeah those guys who host it seem
like they may be in charge or they
created it or whatever but it has this
group effort feel to it and I think that
one of the things that there's a part of
it that people didn't it would never be
it wouldn't it would acquit we would
have stopped yes that's yeah that's what
I'm trying to say if it didn't have that
feel to it that group effort feel it
would not exist so that is what it is
but at the same time there's this this
thing that's been happening has been
happening since the the onset of YouTube
but has kind of taken on a new life and
it is people who are kind of documenting
themselves now a lot of people are doing
it like if you take a look at david
dobrik who's probably the most
successful example of this this is a guy
living an incredible life and
documenting it constantly and then
putting together the best four minutes
in 20 seconds every week week I guess or
win it however often he does it I think
so yeah
and you're along for the ride and I
think that you know it ends up kind of
feeding on itself in a way it's just
like now that my life is my show my life
is going to be produced in a way that's
going to make it an interesting show and
it becomes this thing that like he's
sort of the prime example of like that
genre really working and building an
audience now that is not what we are
going to be doing right because there's
also another version and I'd say if
we're if we're drawing inspiration it's
more from this other version that is
more isolated we're not we're not
constantly going to be filming ourselves
much less our families and our personal
lives yeah but our our idea is to have
specific ideas for what I mean I guess
I'll call it an episode whatever I'll
call it a video it's not an episode
we'll have a particular
idea for video and then we'll execute
that idea well film it ourselves and
then we'll get we'll bring it here and
it will be edited with our you know
under hours in the proper team member
supervision but um it's so it's it's
more like a jenna Marbles video I mean
all our videos at our house I'm not
saying all of our videos are gonna be
one of our homes it's not nothing's
gonna be on the set and it could very
well be at our homes are out in the bow
but it's right if whatever the idea that
we're excited about doing because she
said so takes we're gonna do it she sets
out to do one thing she's like I'm gonna
win I'm gonna do this one thing in this
video like I'm gonna get I'm gonna try
to get my dog to finally sit down on a
wooden floor was like one of her hideous
because she one of her dogs just
wouldn't was afraid to sit on I think
he's he's afraid to sit on wood or
afraid of ceiling carpet I can't I think
was on wood and so and people just
connected with it because it's again
it's so personal right and I think that
there can be two things that are sort of
group produced there can be this
impersonal quality to it that I think we
get the personal with gmm but it it has
the packaging of an impersonal show and
that in and so I think people are kind
of they're wanting that like oh yeah I
just want to I want to see you try to
get your dog to sit on a wooden floor
and if you have if you have a good
personality and you're funny in the
process then this could be something
that actually catches on which is what
you know happens with Jenna she's been
around forever but this is kind of her
latest sort of reinvention of herself
it's really much is really that I'm
gonna do a thing and you're gonna watch
me do it
so thank you Jenna we're definitely
taking inspiration from you on this one
but that's kind of the genre we're
working in because it is working and we
we want to invest in something that's
gonna work as I mean it's one of the
factors that it's like it's gonna it's
gonna work on YouTube I mean what we can
just share the first video that we're
what we're thinking will be the first
video what we're gonna do because it
came from this show and it we started
writing down ideas of examples of things
we might do
and one of the first ones was what if I
got ready to come over to my house and
take a shower in my shower because I've
been bragging about it on this show and
he's been giving me all types of advice
about what to do when I'll see my
neighbor going to work and then let's
let's see what it reckon take a shower
in my shower I can see what it feels
like to be my neighbor when red is being
me taking the advice that he gave me so
that was the idea so I do think a lot of
the things that we might talk about on
your biscuits which tend to be more
personal about things that are happening
in our lives they will spark ideas for
things that we want to kind of delve
into in a different genre in a video
form yeah and you might say well okay
why why not do that on good mythical
morning MA the Buies Creek documentary
on there and everyone loved it I think
the simplest answer to that question is
that while that really worked for sure
that really worked especially the first
two episodes I think maybe the third I
can't one of those episodes didn't get
as much traction as the other which it
may have been the third I can't remember
but in general it worked and people
responded to it but it can be again when
you're thinking about this person who's
kind of checking in on something for the
first time it can be a little bit
confusing if the site I don't really
know what I'm going to get and what we
have found is the general principle is
that once people kind of buy into a show
a channel really a channel because
really on YouTube channels are shows
like people try to do multiple shows on
channels and it and there are exceptions
and we've been able to do things like
launch josh's channel via shows on the
weekends on GMM in general people kind
of mythical kitchen pick that Bell in
general people kind of interpret
channels as this is a show and it has a
kind of a certain format that I can kind
of expect anything different is
confusing and you also don't if it
underperforms for reasons like who knows
how the algorithm treats those
that underperform just because they
didn't meet the expectations of the
channel not because they didn't meet
expectations of quality or entertainment
or you didn't like it ya know so it's
that was one part of it another thing
was we did try a few out of the office
episodes and over the years we've done
we've done many like and I'm not saying
that we're never gonna do out of the
office
episodes honestly especially if there's
like a sponsor involved that's that
that's a lot of the justification for us
doing that type of stuff in the past
like that the back-up plan was sponsored
by Geico but I mean we we did a couple
of things that were at the end of last
year that were different and they didn't
you know we were excited about him but
they didn't perform as well we did like
weed she had wheels cheese wheels on a
car catapulting a hot dog into a bun and
even when we did the the deep dish
turning the car into a deep-dish pizza
site I mean it it it requires a
retooling and a just a reallocation of
resources like all that business E stuff
I was already talking well it requires
so much from us and our team that in
order to justify doing something that
literally takes us and it takes our team
multiple multiple days to get ready for
those things and execute those things
and to build them and then it takes us a
full day at least to shoot them what
ends up happening is you need to get
just from from a business standpoint you
need the return on that investment needs
to be you know a multiple of your
typical views and what we found is is
that not only did it did it not get a
multiple of the typical views it got
significantly less so like putting
cheese wheels on a car or you know kind
of pulling a hot dog didn't get as much
traction as if we just stay at the desk
and do the kinds of things that we do on
GMM so at that point we're like okay if
we have aspirations to do something that
is outside of the office then it kind of
feels like what this is asking for is to
be put in its own place
yeah and then of course we're like are
we really going to have this
conversation are we really going to talk
about putting this on the rhett and Link
channel and before we do I I just just
for this just for the sake of being
complete about the GMM discussion I will
say that and it's not that we're not
gonna continue to innovate on good
mythical morning we are trust me we are
constantly talking about ways to
innovate but doing that within the
confines I mean the physical confines
mostly in the production confines of how
we make good mythical morning trying to
figure out trying new formats it we're
gonna be trying lots of things from
month to month
yeah it doesn't mean that occasionally
we're not gonna but if it's change it up
if it feels totally different I mean
this idea as an as an idea felt totally
different and especially once we had
tried the other things in it you know
you just look at how YouTube behaves and
you start to come to these conclusions
yeah well I think the fact that we just
we've decided to not do it in a way that
we do the GMM episodes which is we bring
the whole crew out and they shoot it
right it's produced like more like a
reality show segment yeah when we go out
and do something whereas what we're
talking about is very much produced like
two dudes who are shooting as honest as
possible but then so yeah so I mean we
started to talk about the the rent link
channel and we you know that that
channel which we used to call the main
channel and it would come up in
conversations every so often whenever
there was something new if we had to
figure out where things on the internet
needed a home like even when we moved
the video version of ear biscuits
somewhere else we were talking about the
red link channel for a second but every
single time I know I would give this
knee-jerk reaction that was like I just
felt very precious about it you know
it's like I don't want to it even if it
has not been anything up there for four
years it's kind of a it's an archive of
where our careers started it's a whole
strata if you're digging down through
the history of how we got to where we
are there's I mean there's multiple
Sharada I'm trying to speak your your
rock language so you'll stay interested
here I love geology but you know what
I'm saying that everything that we tried
that that that failed and succeeded is
there and everything that we put there
by and large was through this filter of
like high production value so it's like
big music videos polished sketches you
know we wouldn't put vlog --is-- type
stuff on there we started our second
channel with vlogs which and eventually
as a way to separate it yeah because I
think you're all just wanted to be
Precious about what it what it is meant
for our careers and also what people
expect from the channel one question
you're answering another question as
well
which is oh man you know some people
might think hi if you guys are gonna
start making videos on the rhettandlink
channel again why not do sketches and
music videos right great question and
the simple answer to that is we the the
the creative energy and efforts that go
into that kind of content music videos
and sketches so we'll just call that
scripted content we're putting a lot of
effort into that but it's again it's
going into what we talked about earlier
which is we're trying to get those kinds
of projects to have the to have the
greatest chances of success because
they're in the right financial model for
themselves and at least right now that
is not an ad driven model I know we're
getting into the weeds and talking
details but you know you guys are smart
and understand this basically you can't
put a bunch of resources into a music
video which takes a lot of time it takes
our personal time both creatively but
then the time it takes to execute at the
time it takes the money it takes to
actually make it and we made a lot of
those videos back in the day and we did
it with the help of sponsors sometimes
we just went in the hole a lot a lot of
videos we just lost money on because we
were kind of investing in people's kind
of perception of what we were doing but
at this point with so many things going
on the amount of time
that it would take to make that kind of
content it just there's no world in
which we can justify that type of effort
at least for now while we're doing all
these other things maybe there's a world
in the distant future where we've
stopped doing a bunch of other things
and we decide hey let's make some good
old-fashioned music videos music on the
right link channel but as of right now
there's just another world for that so
what that leaves is well it's so the
scripted content is a big creative itch
we're investing in a lot and scratching
it in places where the money makes sense
yeah so that it could actually be made
and we're not just retreading ground on
that doing the same stuff we were doing
on that channel because it would just be
the same stuff it's like we want to
build yeah but you were saying yes so
that so the the idea of I mean there is
this precious quality to it that you're
talking about which is like it took all
this time and you know the things that
you put the most effort into in your
entire career when you talk about a
single piece of content so like effort
per minute yeah was the highest ratio
the highest ratio ever lived in those
Rhett link videos why then do something
that maybe the effort per minute or the
creative input per minute is a little
bit different when it comes to a vlog
and I think my answer to that question
is yeah but I first of all I think that
that's selling our ideas for this
channel for these videos short because I
do think that they're they are going to
be a creative expression now they're not
gonna be like they don't have scripts or
anything like that and we were shooting
it's totally different smarmy amorous we
I think is but I still have I have such
high hopes for the 5 on a final product
we're very excited and engaged
creatively in in what these vlogs are
gonna be and what we're gonna learn how
it's going to evolve as we're doing them
and what we could have just started a
new channel and and stayed precious with
the rhett and Link channel but and I
think you convinced me of this it was
hey it can just be a new era of that
channel we got all these we got all
these subscribers I mean that's those
numbers are real you know you
can't just you got to come to grips with
that I mean if we're launching an
entirely new channel from scratch we're
already doing that with mythical kitchen
you want to do that with two channels
totally from scratch when we can
mitigate it and we have we feel very
strongly that a mythical kitchen isn't
completely free no it's not either but
and when we know we don't have we're not
saving the Renton Link channel for
something else we don't have a vision
for it so we're excited about this it is
rhettandlink I mean it's that's the
simplest thing for me so let's just it's
called the Renault 4 and what what is
the most authentically rhettandlink
content that were contemplating right
now it's the Wiz the ones that we just
that we make which which then brings me
to I think the the the biggest reason
that way that we made the decision and I
think it's it's what I already talked
about about the experience like the
friendship experience I described on
your birthday when it's like we're
hanging out we're having a good time and
then we found ourselves wanting to do
Instagram stories about getting a McRib
just to I felt like the motive was the
was the purest it could be in terms of
wanting to share something on the
internet like we're actually having a
good time this is funny we'll have even
more fun if we if we film it and share
it I think and then having that
experience plays right into me being
excited about this I just think that
it's it's about us cultivating our
friendship coming up with things that we
want to make videos about that it we're
just gonna have fun doing it like I
can't I say it's not like everything
else we do isn't that but it's
everything else is different in all the
projects were working on there they
don't have this like the most raw honest
version of I just wanted I want to do
this to have fun you can watch it if you
want to
I actually I feel very refreshed that
I'm not trying to create something
that's really gonna work that's gonna
take the internet by storm I don't feel
like we have some external assignment
- to make this a success for anybody
else
I think I'm I I'm very excited because I
feel like it's gonna be fun for us to do
the stuff that we want to do you know
coming over to my house and taking a
shower it sounds fun yeah but it's you
know I I'm definitely not about adding
something
adding something to our plate that we
have to do every week that it's it
starts to feel like something we have to
do you know we talked about why your
biscuits is such an outlet and I seen
this in the same way and I just want to
say it because I think that's kind of a
a litmus test as we as we start doing
these vlogs are like okay why are we
doing that and what what's the primary
focus what's the secondary focus and
then because we are very much gonna be
focused on the the creative exercise of
making these things as entertaining as
possible and I'm sure there'll be some
like some will growing pains well I'm
sure we'll get into it about what the
damn thumbnail should be you know it's
like and it it's it's frustrating but
it's if we if we keep it as a secondary
motivation and the primary motivation is
we're gonna have fun together doing the
things that we're excited about doing
take it or leave it then I think those
secondary things which we will have to
deal with and work with the team on and
that it'll it'll they'll take care of
itself
unite it in that order it will be the
word that were your your your the
process that you're talking about is
optimization so right yeah so the ideas
will be optimized meaning that the title
and the thumbnail for whatever we decide
to do will be optimized so as to
generate the most interest but there is
a point in which optimization can become
your goal like you actually are starting
with a title and a thumbnail and then
building an idea out from that and I
think we do that a lot with GMM and it's
almost a it's a the joke is that we
conceptualize these ridiculous things
and then we because of the way that it
works
we absolutely it's easy for us to have
fun within that yeah you the concept
that we built you create a nice thing
delivers on that and I yeah that
optimisation we found a way to make it
work for ourselves but I think this is
coming from a different place right it's
coming from a different place which is
like you said and I think that the
reason it's so appropriate to talk about
it on your biscuits is because I think
it comes from the same place not just ok
ear biscuits has become a place where we
catch up and talk and maybe have
conversations that we get so busy that
we might not be able to justify just
stopping and having these conversations
yeah in the midst of a week but we can
we do it we were forced to do it through
through your biscuits but it'll force us
to have fun together well no but I'm
seriously like you know there's a
there's a you've got like and I think
this this kind of plays into the there
is a generation gap we are coming into
this as kind of the old guys trying it
right yeah you know as guys who are into
their 40s have wives and children and
got kids getting ready to go to college
and not too far from now yeah running a
business that has gotten bigger and more
unwieldy than we ever anticipated
our lives are regimented and systemized
and just more complicated complex than
we could have ever imagined whereas if
you take somebody who's just like hey
I'm 20 years old and I don't really have
anybody to answer to except myself and
me and my friends live in a house
together we're constantly doing stupid
[ __ ] and filming it yeah well you are
naturally that's fertile ground for
these vlogs that feel super connecting
but for us it's like if we were decide
to decide to like hey we're gonna do
what David Ober does it we're gonna
carry around this camera with us at all
times you'd be like well now they're in
a meeting and then they left that
meeting and went to another meeting and
then they took their kid to this recital
and now they went kay there's another
meeting like it wouldn't
that exciting the life of a the life of
a 42 year old head of a company isn't
really not that exciting
so we basically tricked our team in
order to scheduling time for us to leave
the office and have fun together
exactly that's that's what I'm saying
I'm saying that like where are these ear
biscuit conversations create this
platform for us to catch up and have the
kinds of conversations that friends
should be having but when friends get
busy adult friends a lot of times don't
have yeah the conversations that we
would have had in college sitting out
you know underneath the the stairs and
I'm dorm well what are the kinds of
things that we may have decided to do
when we were in college or single before
we got married and be like hey you why
don't you come and take a shower in my
shower and see what it's and I'm gonna
see what it's like to be me from my
neighbor's perspective that's a dumbass
idea but it's a great idea for it would
be as a fit it's a hard one thing to
justify be hard to justify the turnover
in the middle of my Saturday when I'm
right when I'm hanging out with my
family whatever and so exactly so now we
have this now Lucy's thing at or taking
a nap by yourself because we don't know
where you are right so what she just
added but now we have this outlet to be
like we're gonna do the things that a
couple of guys without any
responsibilities might choose to do
it'll be so much fun we have to do it in
a responsible way which means we have to
monetize it and you talk about being
okay you know I'm just trying to you
know dance like nobody's watching
but I do hope you watch but when I told
the kids so Lillian Lincoln I was like
yeah we're we're gonna be we're gonna
start vlogging we're filming it
ourselves we're doing it on the
rhettandlink channel and I was quiet and
they got this look on their eye and they
were they were quiet and I think it was
I'm not gonna be in it no I think it was
you trying to be like david dobrik i
think is really what they're like come
on dad aren't you too old for this they
didn't say it and maybe that's just my
insecurities but I don't care well I
think we are too old for that
yeah to become yeah like
we are too old I mean Jason Nash buddies
around with with David and I think he's
he's he's made some different choices
than us and I probably am to do that I
don't know but the fact is is we are
coming into this as we are two dads we
are we are two were two are two lifelong
best friends who are dads who are
husbands who do have very busy
lifestyles and but I think that's part
of what we're bringing to it honestly
you know I feel like you're always
looking for you know industry term is
what's it what's the white space you
know what's the open space in this
particular thing that you're trying to
get into right you don't want to get
into something or try to do something
and you're feeling exactly the same
space or you're competing for the same
space that somebody already has and
while in a sense you can't help that
when you're doing YouTube in general I
do think that we got to bring something
a little bit different right
obviously we bring a slightly different
since there's middle-aged men showers
check there's a little something
different about our sense of humor that
maybe if you're a fan of this or gmm
that you kind of be like okay well I
can't get that anywhere else but at
least to the best of my knowledge I do
think that guys who are only getting
older trying to maintain an experience a
friendship that's fun and maintains a
youthful we come out with a lot filled
no I'm just guys we're only getting
older that's not that's not these are
their best to maintain their childhood
friendship yeah yeah filming each other
but I do think that that is is what it
is it's not and we don't have an
entourage I mean our entourage is is our
wives and kids and they're probably not
gonna be making a whole lot of
appearances yeah they might be making
some appearances from time to time as as
the idea requires it maybe I don't know
but we're definitely not making any
promises about that I don't know how
it's going to be in general we're not
making promises about anything because
it's I don't know once once we once we
really get into it I anticipate that
it'll it'll evolve it'll evolve we're
gonna do it we're gonna learn as we go
and we're not trying to have this like
master plan as to what this is supposed
to accomplish it really is in the way
once we made the switch you know we
started ear biscuits it was very
intentional we're like we're gonna be
the Internet's answer to Marc Maron's
WTF podcast more or less let's do
profiles and people who the internet
finds interesting the show has now
through several iterations evolved to
what it is now which is just the two of
us catching up and talking with each
other about things that interest us and
I think that that willingness to evolve
is the reason that ear biscuits
continues to exist and I think that
we're starting this just like hey this
isn't started there is no master plan
it's kind of starting in the place that
your biscuits has ended up which is like
what's the video answer to what we've
sort of established on this podcast and
I do think that's the final piece that
we haven't talked about is just trying
something new I you know I I also have
this a little insecurity that's like
people are gonna think like what I put
on my kids I put on other people's like
they're gonna think that we're just
trying to get on the bandwagon oh you
know well markiplier and his friends
started doing it every day and so that
really seal the deal it's like I had
nothing to do with it cuz we we we write
it before we have made the decision and
then we saw that we're like well we
don't have to tell on that because it
doesn't matter yeah yeah it's fine
but it's for us it's an it's entirely
new yeah and that's where we where we
get the most engaged when it's like I
don't have I don't know how this is
gonna turn out I don't know how this is
gonna feel I don't know anything about
this so that's exciting yeah so you know
what we hope you enjoy it
subscribe to the rhett and Link channel
click the bell don't ask any questions
yeah I mean we're gonna you're along for
the ride like I said this is it's such a
new it's such a new idea you're gonna
your
be a part of what it becomes so thank
you in advance for being along for the
ride yeah and there's a there's a reddit
thread there's a rhett and Link reddit
thread which is like what does it what
do you talk about on the rent link
reddit thread whenever I go over there
I'm like people trying to figure it out
it's like there's a good mythical
morning thread there's an ear biscuits
thread I think I saw that there's a
thread dedicated only to Stevie that
makes sense anyways we spice up that
rhett and Link thread over there
redditors yeah you just revealed the
real reason for all of this link just is
to give the comment thread something to
talk about okay with that I'm going to
end with a wreck Oh 2020 wreck this
better be good
well you kick off before you built it up
too much this is this is something that
has been out since the middle of 2019
but I old stuff okay I don't think that
it got enough recognition and enough
appreciation for how innovative it was
just a new posture for making a
recommendation yeah just just in case
there's an earthquake it's called my
favorite shapes with Julio Torres Julio
Torres is a guy who is a writer on SNL
he's also on that Louis bukas with Fred
Armisen which I still haven't watched
that I've heard many many great things
about I don't wreck it if you haven't
I'm not recommending that even though I
can only imagine it's great don't knock
it till you try it and don't wreck it to
your Brackett he has the most innovative
now listen I'm gonna be honest with you
some of you will absolutely hate it
because it is just weird as hell and
some of you who like things that are
weird as hell will love it like me and
all I'm gonna say is his whole stand-up
special is him standing in front of a
conveyor belt but it's just bringing
things around that he then talks about
in the premises my favorite shapes okay
and I just really don't build it up too
much liked it so I think it's on HBO
if it's not the you'll find it just
search my favorite shapes with the Leo
Torres and go in and enjoy something
incredibly wonderfully weird there you
have it we kicked off 2020 we got one we
got a notch on our belt we got a ear
biscuit knotch
and you take a notch out of my bill I've
had a urinate for at least 35 I can pee
as well who's gonna get your biscuits
let us know we're gonna cross streams
this is this is the place and I guess in
the comments of that first video when it
comes out a couple of Saturdays from now
let us know what you think about our
thought process and in this new endeavor
are you in are you out are you up are
you down hashtag your biscuits we'll
talk about you next week about our
holidays to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best